[Music]
well today's council meeting was
actually quite a light agenda it's my
first one back around the table and I've
enjoyed being back the Oaxaca
gatekeepers Lodge has been moved into
the O hooker domain and it was approved
today
and we also are looking at ceilings and
councilors over to cement our sister
city relationship with honor she which
is a very important part of
international relations today the
council acknowledged neil falconer he
received the Queen's Service Medal and
the Year's Honours for services to
communications and broadcasting and we
also farewelled
a very loved colleague Marie Bunny who's
been our drainage manager for many years
and also bought an understanding of tech
con amore and today o and the council
he's been a big part of our way out a
group and in fostering our relationship
with NATO already and he will be very
sorely missed
[Music]
from now on our meetings are going to
get a lot busier with little LTP coming
up here ten year plan and there's
obviously a lot of discussions to be had
and a lot of submissions to come in from
the community
[Music]